ah
man if you're like me you remember this
time during covid-19 where we were
locked we're in lockdown it was it was
terrible I felt like I was trapped
behind glass I couldn't go outside I
hated it but of course uh it's not as
bad as some people had it during Co they
they lost loved ones um and of course uh
they could get sick themselves so it's
kind of strange that we're now back to
the situation um where we can you know
have a conference we can go out to bars
and have fun uh for for a lot of people
it is very much like uh a pandemic never
happened or will never happen again am I
still yeah um for the people that think
a pandemic will never happen again I
have some bad news uh pandemics are
inevitable uh and then some good news
attached to that is that we can reduce
the
risk so this is a quote from uh the
leader of the PM 2 project um she is um
responsible for increasing pandemic
preparedness in the EU
uh uh and what what does reducing the
risk mean in this case because I think
it's kind of uh very important to
understand what that means it's that we
can try to mitigate pandem pandemic when
it comes so it's very important to have
really good data when it come when when
you are confronted with a situation like
that uh but it might also mean if we're
very lucky that we can actually
completely smash a pandemic uh from ever
happening depending on our response so
um this is a
very very far away from what I'm doing
but I'm sort of try try to work towards
that goal so who am I I work at uh the
rfm which is the Dutch Institute for
public health and environment of the uh
so of the Netherlands it's um just to be
sure because I know there's a lot of
Americans in here I put a little map to
show you where the Netherlands actually
is it's this tiny little country in
Europe um so I I got hired by the rfm
two and a half years ago um to work on
the covid-19 um pipelines um so they
they were a completely new concept to
the rvm because U we had pre the
previously just did a lot of stuff
manually or sometimes in in SAS scripts
but not very automated so I got hired to
um to um to help help set this up and
help uh run it
um now that covid-19 has died down a lot
fortunately we have switched our efforts
to uh other diseases and I'm going to
talk today about the influenza pipeline
so the the common flu and why the common
flu it's because um the flu has been
actually one of the main uh sources of
pandemics in the recent
history so there is already a a pipeline
for this uh previously already existed
so very Sim to talk we had before there
was like a mess of data going in you had
to do a bunch of magic and then uh bunch
of stuff goes out um for different
reasons though so it could be Hospital
data uh data from GPS uh nursing homes
municipalities or statistics from
populations and we we get handed a lot
of different types of data so it could
be from a data source database could be
FTP or for example just emails with CSV
files and what we did is where we we
clean it up and then we um uh create
reports for uh experts to analyze um and
then make sure that
um it's it's not out of control so this
already exists so we already have a
pipeline in place so how how bad can
this this existing pipeline be so I have
a tiny little demo here um of an actual
job that someone had to do every single
week um so they never figured out how to
put numbers above a bar chart so the
solution was to go to a graphical
software and then type in the numbers
from Excel sheet so you can also make
typos when you do this so this is
obviously very dangerous and it's just
because she inherited this job this way
this is just how how she was thought to
do
it um so obviously we need to automate
this this whole process this is not okay
we learned a lot from Co um it was a
little bit messy and very chaotic during
Co so now we have time to design our
pipelines um so let's automate the whole
thing and I'm kind of a nerd and I go to
these conference and I get all these
ideas and there some of these things are
quite obvious uh was Data bricks I also
had fire fire on here uh of air flow for
for orchestration of course yeah so many
ideas that I want to implement uh but
epidemiologist reaction more something
like this uh the reason for that is that
um
the reason the epid epidemiologists even
involved in this that they have to be
really close to what what they're doing
to the data so um I will explain uh a
little bit reason for why that is a
little bit later but they have to be the
ones that are running the pipeline are
actually uh constructing uh the the data
themselves that's sort of the way it's
set up at rfm right now so this doesn't
work so I proposed a couple of steps for
a properly planned pipeline uh and I
will go through them one by one so the
first thing is we have to determine the
requirements for a minimum viable
product or a minimum viable pipeline if
you will um so to explain that I will go
back again to covid-19 because that's
where I have the most experience at rfm
and also because I was in a very similar
situation to where the uh
epidemiologists are right now at the
rvm um so two and a half years ago when
I started there was one of the tasks
that we were just handed handed um is I
had to sit behind the computer every day
someone of my team had to sit by the
computer every day at 10: a.m. and press
control enter um we had to run one
script and sit behind the computer and
watch it go uh the reason for that is
that things were moving so fast that we
were constantly adding stuff to our code
and that was running into um yeah errors
so what would happen is that if we would
run it automatically um the job would
fill and we would have to then run run
the whole thing again and figure out
where the bug was but the job was 2
hours long and we needed the data in 3
hours so um that was very challenging so
why um sorry so what went wrong so our
error buzziness was really low because
we were constantly changing uh the code
and because we're constantly chasing the
code we had to do it manually which
means I was wasting a lot of time and
our pipelines were not reproducible at
all um and this is of course because we
were changing them on the fly when we're
editing and I don't have logs I don't
have uh Version Control for it so that's
kind of bad so these were like the main
things that we had to challenge for for
our minimum viable pipeline so some of
these things are just agreements that we
have to do with our team so whoever's
working on it so we decide we will not
use graphpad and then also image
software now we'll do everything in R
and we have to have a version control
system and it's not just installing git
and running it once in a while no we
have to have agreements about how to
actually use it
um I will not focus on this too much
today um I will talk a bit more about uh
the other part um it's very similar to
the targets package so that leaves you
guys a nice question to ask on
slido um so I will talk so so I wanted
to create break down our pipeline into
more modular chunks so if you look at
this little pseudo code that I have here
this is very similar to what our old pip
line would look like the thing that I
would have to run at at 10 in the
morning um we're importing a bunch of
data um we're transforming the data and
then we're saving all of the data and if
something went wrong during this huge
transformation step in the middle then I
would have to go in fix it and then
rerun the step and the step below Etc so
we proposed to do in a very similar Mana
to the Target package um to to sort of
uh separate this out and uh this is also
um what sort of talked about this
morning by uh at JD stock um what was it
again separate concerns and and uh
minimize complexity or separate
concerns so here we
are by creating modular chunks and
breaking the problem down we are
separating concerns so each step is
smaller and easier to tackle and
basically I'm also saying I'm equally
genius as JD
so just just hanging out so um what we
do here is we have our definition file
where we say each step here script one
script two to has an input and an output
and then we have some way of running
this as a pipeline very similar to the
tme um so here there's our definitions
again and this would look into this this
again this directed a graph this is what
what get
run um so that is sort of now our
minimum viable Pipeline and the next
step is to design a framework around
that that would scale across
organization so this is what I was
talking about earlier that um the
epidemiology actually needs to be
involved here the reason for that is
that we're not just doing influenza we
are we have a lot of disease that we
have to monitor and each of them has
their own unique quirks um unique data
sources and it's really the
epidemiologist tasked to be really close
to the data source and really contact
them uh and there's there's a lot of
like just emailing back and forth that
us data scientists can do so we we rely
on the epidemiologist to to know what
what's happening and our our job is just
to make their life easier so we have to
create this framework um where they can
focus just on the most important steps
so they have to understand what what
what do I need to create and we help
them create this in to break it down
into smaller steps and create this graph
and so they can focus on what script one
does what script two does in this
example and what we do is we uh try to
abstract away all of the stuff around it
so these are the most important things
that I was talk about earlier that was
missing during the co covid-19 scripts
is that we had we we didn't have logging
so we we just add that as a layer in
there um and also of course we need to
go from this definition file to this
this dag in the first place so that's
that's something we do and we help with
the import and the export of the data
fil so we try to make it in a such a way
um where it it does should not matter
what you have what what kind of data you
put in or how you put the data in and
how you export the data um also so for
the future so the epidemiologist besides
making this this dag and and um separate
scripts we just have to run pipeline
which is T make in uh targets package uh
and we in the back in the back end um we
we were on we create a package for
internal tooling and um we we create the
Run pipeline function um so we restart
the logs we interpret all of the steps
and we Loop through our um uh loop
through the
to um yeah import the date execute the
script export the
data so now next to the third step
that's to allow spa space for
extensions
um this is the pipeline as I showed you
before uh and what we wanted to do is to
have the possibility to have very uh
specific um to allow for specific
extensions that are really important to
us so uh for example you can imagine
that they want to visualize this dag
which is relatively simple thing to do
so that you can see what they're doing
we want to add uh static code checks as
an option so that uh we're making sure
that they are doing what they say
they're doing um we and a very important
one is to add metadata so when you are
running a script we can have metadata be
collected and be uh published in uh in
internal rfm wide um database or for
example for
scheduling yeah so the idea behind is
that the epidemiologist doesn't have to
change their code they just have to
update our internal package and then the
rum pipeline transforms uh and adds
these extra things so um the static code
check would be something like check
steps um the method data would just be
one part of the loop and uh they can
have a separate visualization function
and of course there's many ideas that
are floating around that we want to
do um so what is the current status we
we now actually we're finished with
fully automating this flu surveyance at
least in the form of the minimum viable
pipeline uh and we have now started with
20 new pipelines so that's actually
quite uh a lot of stuff happening in
parallels a lot of epidemiologist
working at the same time and we are
developing our package also at the same
time so we're we're quite busy uh so the
first big extension to the uh package
would be U metadata so we're working now
on getting um yeah defining what what is
metadata in our case and how are we
storing that and sharing that across the
rfm
so to summarize my talk um using
collaboration and clever design we
created a scalable framework for disease
surveyance that gets us one step closer
to preventing future pandemics I mean
preventing is okay I hope so but this is
a long summary and I like the seven PS
of the military so I summarize it even
further uh plant pathogen processing
pipelines for pandemic
preparedness so that's much easier to
remember right okay so thank you for
your
time thank you so much appreciate it um
so the the other projects that you have
right now Crea the other pipelines are
there still about surveillance or is it
something else that you're trying to
track so right now we're mostly focused
on getting surveyance out there uh like
maybe may I fail to mention it a little
bit but we want to have it as
standardized as possible so that as data
scientists can still help theologist
because if they start creating their own
thing and it's really hard to support
them um so it has to be as standardized
as possible um so that's so we're
focusing now on getting survey in spy
plans on up and running uh but we also
have things like modeling happening uh
that we might extend our our
functionality to in the future yeah um
but U one yeah so there the main there's
also research happening and we're not
probably not going to support that much
cuz it's going to be unique and every
every time it will not have a lot of
repeating repeating pipeline stuff
happening so we're mostly focusing on on
surveillance first
yeah um and also the use of the ammo
file what was the the reasoning behind
using that particular method yeah um so
yeah the targets just uses R code to the
Target package uses R code um I find y
to be more readable and
I I looked I looked at a couple because
Target is the only one that's really
mature for R I think but other uh
programming languages have a similar
thing and uh I I find it really um much
more readable if it's yo it's just it's
just me um for example the cadro package
I think also uses this python thing also
uses yo so it's more about relability to
me yeah yeah I agree well uh
thank you again I appreciate it um if
you um join me again to thank him
Patrick thank you so
[Applause]
much